the president critics include leaders of
very small countries in the Pacific
Ocean they are at risk of being overcome
by rising sea levels Seth Doane is in
care bus and island nation in the heart
of the affected area news of the Trump
administration's decision to pull out of
the Paris climate Accords has traveled
quickly making it all of the way here to
this island nation in the South Pacific
considered to be among the most
vulnerable and likely among the first to
feel the effects of climate change much
of the nation of Carabas is less than
six feet above sea level and some
predictions indicate that oceans could
rise high enough to wipe out this entire
country around 145 million people around
the world live less than three feet
above sea level
one woman here told us that she believes
the people in the little countries rely
on the big countries and big polluters
to be leaders in this field and where
does this decision leave them she asked
for CBS this morning
I'm Seth Doane in Carabas in the South
Pacific the beautiful South Pacific yeah
I mean think about that entire small
islands can just be wiped out by rising
sea levels Seth Doane said he'll see us
when he sees us meanwhile he's enjoying
the opposite and feel amazing from there
they